what's the meaning of life
wow that's beautiful
i think that the meaning of of life is
uh
is in part
um what euron touches on when when he
says that
uh that um
that productive work labor creativity is
is at the heart of what it is to be
human
i i
i just think that there there are
some more arenas and maybe we even agree
with a lot of them and i i on a lot of
them
to be human is to
inherit a world which is imperfect
terribly imperfect and perfect in many
ways
and uh and and god created it
that way he created a world which is
terribly lacking
and he created us with the ability to
stand up and to say
i can change the direction of this i can
do something to change the direction of
this i can take the time and the
abilities that are given to me to be a
partner with god in creating the world
it's not going to stay the way it was
before me it'll be something
different
maybe a little bit maybe a lot
but that's that is that is the heart
that is the key that is the meaningful
life is to be a partner with god in
creating the world so that it is
moving that much more in the right
direction
rather than
the way we found so nudge even if a
little bit the direction of the world
well uh
you're you're on uh you've actually been
talking on your program about life quite
a bit
uh so let me ask the same question
and i i never tire you asking this
question
what do you think is the is the meaning
of this holiday i mean i don't believe
in god so it god doesn't play a role in
in in my view of of the meaning of life
i i think the meaning of life is to live
i like to say to live with a capital l
it's to embrace it and and
a good theorem in a sense you were born
into a world and as human beings
one of the things that makes us very
different than other animals is our
capacity to change that world
we can actually go out there and change
the world around us we can change it
materially
through production and through we can
change it spiritually through changing
the ideas of of people we can we can
change the direction into which humanity
works we can um we can create a little
universe part of
the i think part of the joy of creating
a family is to create a little universe
right we're creating a little world uh
around us that's part of the the joy
and there is joy and family that's uh
make it all about uh difficulty and hard
work i agree i agree you know but part
of the part of the the idea of getting
married is is to create a little world
in which you and your spouse are
creating something that didn't exist
before in in in building something
building a universe but it's really to
live i mean one of the things that
i i see and and that saddens me is is
wasted lives
it's people who just
just cruise through life they just they
just they get bored they get born in a
particular place they never challenge it
they never question
they just
you know they live die and nothing
really happened nothing really changed
they didn't produce they didn't make
anything of their life and produce here
again in the in their largest sense
so to me it's it's and every aspect of
life you know as you know because you've
listened to my show i love art i love
aesthetics i i love the experience of
great art
you know i love relationships i you know
i i love
producing i'm you know i like
business i like that that aspect of it
um and and i think i think people people
are shallow in in so many parts of their
lives which saddens me i mean if we if
you had 8 billion people in this planet
even if it never grew even if we just
stayed at 8 billion but the 8 billion
all lived
fully wow i mean
what an amazing place this would be what
an amazing experience we would have so
so to me that is the meaning is just
make the most that you have a short
period of time on earth
and that's it this is it and live it
experience it fully and and challenge
yourself and push yourself and and let
me just say something about optimism
about you know one source of hope for me
in the world in which we live right now
is that there are people who do that at
least in certain realms of of their
lives right and and i'm inspired
and and i know a lot of people don't
like me for this but i'm inspired for
example by silicon valley in spite of
all the the political disagreements i
have with them and all of that i'm
inspired by people
inventing new technologies and building
i'm inspired by by the people you talk
to about artificial intelligence and
about about new ideas and about pushing
the boundaries of science those things
are exciting and it's it's terrific to
see a world that i think generally is in
decline yet there these pockets in which
people are still
creating new uh new ventures and new
ideas and new things
that that inspires me and it gives me
hope that that is not dead that in spite
of the decay that's in our culture
there's still pockets where
that spirit of being human is still is
still alive and well yeah they inspire
me as well yeah and they truly live with
the capital l and maybe i can join a
star maybe you can also put a little bit
of love with the capital l out there as
well
uh you're on
you knew i would end it that way
wouldn't you uh you're on your arm thank
you so much this is a huge honor i
really enjoyed the debate yesterday i
really enjoyed the conversation today
that you spend your valuable time with
me just means a lot thank you so much
this is amazing
you